[Música]
hoy recuerda
para nosotros pueden útiles en este
momento del circuito que nos pareció
pasar a la distancia y la pregunta puede
compartir de nuevo soccer star podemos
ver que nosotros tenemos la posibilidad
de sentirnos ellos
siempre estamos requeridos para de
mirándonos a nosotros mismos cómo
podemos compartir
como educadora linda convencida de que
la educación encuentra de transformación
entonces empecé cómo podemos hacer para
transformar desde la escuela desde el
jardín en este caso colores y poder
dedicarnos para que nuestras solidarios
para que puedan salir de estos mínimos y
en la punta de lo de sus necesidades
así empezamos este proyecto
para la ficción
de los trajes que salen a la gente
vimos cuáles grandes características nos
disfrazamos cubanos mezclamos historias
armamos súper autos que podía trasladar
lo hicimos muchas cosas desde la
aparición y mostaza que los superen más
gente que usar un traje que tenían
diferentes superpoderes
pero que no eran reales no existen en la
vida real
pero en la vida
los células
y cuando quiera no sirve a todas esas
personas que puedan hacer algo por los
demás
hoy es como decíamos de una sociedad
siempre
conocimos a distintos personas que
habían hecho cosas importantes y
perdidos en sus casas junto con sus
familias
pero digamos quedar solamente en la
información
necesitábamos poner la información en
acción y transformar
nuestra primera visión puede ayudar a un
comedor de casa
y entonces hicimos unas generales
teníamos trabajadores conocieron obras
especialmente para cambiar alimentos
2017 2 para ganar
a este comedor
todos los momentos no suelen ser fáciles
pues la verdadera no fue tan bien como
esperábamos no tuvimos tanto éxito pero
no
una visión vial
salió el tema de los bienes muchos
tenemos familiares como esta situación
de inundación
y obviamente
vamos a hacer nosotros equipos
necesitaban estas operaciones
entonces solidarios
a distribuirlos
[Música]
por cosas para
y empezar a poner lo mejor de una
entonces siempre hacemos algo al
comisario de nosotros que lo vamos a dar
y cambiarlo por lamentaciones destinamos
luego de muchos éxitos
iba la malicia de los serios
dentro de las misiones pueden relacionar
a donde tu manera
del jardín que vivía de una situación de
vulnerabilidad habitacional de otras
cosas que llamamos debemos hacer para
ayudar a mejorar en los negocios posible
y se encuentra bajo el agua
poniente un poco con calefacción
lo único que tenía estaba del vecino el
celestial
mi primera idea fue
fundada para
porque generalmente a veces los chicos
no siempre
y cuando este sentido lo compartí con
las familias y vieron cuando una idea
compartida
grande
y la familia
[Música]
una familia y eso llegarán las
repeticiones
así que junto con las familias
coordinamos acciones y respuestas a esas
fuerzas solidarios los metimos
también
en platos dulces
y la compra
exclusivamente
le compraba cosas a la ducha a
legislador
también a todo eso
y no sólo eso sino que también podemos
comprarlo en las zapatillas otra
trastada que tenía
y fue muy curioso porque al contrario de
lo que pueden decir muchos profesionales
como los demás
[Música]
pregunta
pero me dicen
y cuando nosotros nos abrazamos en el
jardín
y propusimos abrazar a la manera como
dedicamos
el amor porque los chicos le abrazarán
es ya
y dice lo que hace cuando cuando sale
elimina
mi corazón
[Música]
en el corazón
de quemaduras cuando la necesitamos a
diario
y una mamá necesita
genial así que todos los esfuerzos
fueron comprendidos y no tuviera que más
todos los días
no puedes vender su casa
y así las mediciones si has tenido
porque hay muchas visiones más y albanos
y algunos podrían decir otra vez más que
trabajar en él
sí porque todos somos diferentes
y eligen como marcamos solamente los
niños y las familias fueron todos los
corrillos del cual salimos de la zona de
confort para crecer para ver a otros
chicos que necesitan hablar con
situaciones que podríamos ayudar y así
descubrimos que los éxitos
en nuestro corazón y sobre todo en
nosotros los educadores de cómo está la
responsabilidad de dejar la mirada
educar nuestros ojos se de civilizarlos
bueno
y es lo que quiero marcar y precisamente
necesitamos cambiar
[Música]
y vamos a descubrir la posibilidad de
que dentro de nosotros siempre
[Aplausos]